greg saw the suicide squad without me
so you know what i decided to do i'm
going to cinemark
with all of my closest friends who are
mostly greg's closest friends
and we're gonna have ourselves a private
viewing party so he's not invited
149 you could see any movie you want
with your friends
not for free for 149 but that's a way
better deal than a normal movie so you
know what
come with me i'm inviting you guys
because greg's not invited
let's do this i really think you could
just watch this movie what are you doing
here
i liked it that much that i i wanted to
step on your toes
it'll mainly be your video don't [ __ ]
viewing let's go
john's friends
[Music]
guys we just watched the suicide squad
not to be confused
with suicide squad and now we're gonna
go around the room we're gonna collect
everyone's opinions and see if it lives
up to the rotten tomatoes
yeah then we'll just get a discussion
going we've got a lot of opinions to go
through here we'll
start a fight let's do this all right
olivia what did you think about the
movie
i thought it was great i loved it
sebastian and king shark are the best
part of it you feel connected to all the
characters and you care about them and
their outcomes and what happens with
them it's more intertwined
with the audience than the first one
jason dolan did you like it love it
hate it what's your thoughts i really
liked it i'm definitely looking forward
to a suicide squad
and uh harley quinn best part
[Laughter]
all right jaby coy did you love it like
it hate it what'd you think it was cool
i
definitely liked it more than the other
suicide squad less than guardians of the
galaxy more than guardians of the galaxy
two
and i would never watch it again okay
tyler i live in fan theory tv did you
love it like it hate it what'd you think
i loved it i'm not a dc fan and i liked
it more than both guardians
i like the visuals that they used and i
thought it was my kind of
[ __ ] up sense of humor and yeah it was
great it was beautiful
josh did you love it like it hate it
give your thoughts
i liked it uh this is what i'll say the
first two thirds i thought the tone
and pacing was kind of off and i wasn't
quite getting into it but the third act
definitely kind of saved the movie for
me in some ways
some of the actors that are on this
poster i was excited to see and i don't
feel like we really got enough of i'm
not gonna get into spoilers and i think
the harley quinn
side story just didn't really work for
me it felt like they kind of had to
shoot her in there a little bit
but overall i like james gunn i think he
had fun at the rated r
do whatever you want and get gory it's
definitely gory it's definitely radar
but yeah i have some reservations about
overall
but not a bad time whatever
my friend did you love it like it hated
what you think i
really liked it i didn't quite love it
because i don't feel like
by the end of the movie i had like this
strong sense of like
rallying like yes they did it but you
know i really enjoyed the ride it
definitely presented itself
as a suicide squad movie the one we were
waiting for for years lived at the
potential of what the first one had
while also kind of navigating a moral
gray area of what a suicide squad movie
could be i had a blast of a time
and they did some interesting things
with harley quinn that the other two
movies hadn't done
james gunn sensibilities portrayed her
in quite a different way and yeah i had
a grand old time with the thing
i thought it was pretty fun i mean it
was definitely rated r
i don't know why when i went into the
movie i didn't quite expect it to be
quite that gory but i was just like oh
oh okay but
it was pretty fun i like the characters
and uh king shark
is the best some issues i won't say
but yeah it was it was fun overall and
visually stunning so there
all right john what did you think about
it my friend i thought this was really
fun and i like that it breathed like an
actual movie it had a lot of reveals
that i wasn't expecting
from it and i think that was my favorite
aspect like it seemed to have just a
little pinch more on its mind than i
thought it would and it said some things
i wasn't expecting a movie like this to
try and say
i really enjoyed the ensemble i like the
irreverent gory
sort of troma edges that james gunn gets
to bring with him to these big corporate
studio gigs and uh yeah
i would recommend it all right guys so
should you see this in the theaters
yes
[Music]
all right since gregory talked for 12
minutes about this
i got two people with me i feel like we
could take up 36.
where should we start greg well john who
were some of your favorite highlight
characters in this movie
definitely uh the joker played by jared
leto my favorite
no i mean there's so many great
characters across this and no matter how
much time anybody spends on screen there
are a lot of people who really make an
impact
i mean it's hard not to call out polka
dot man rat catcher two
because they are so prominent ddk
especially
i mean yeah that's the thing is then you
start thinking about all the other
characters and like tdk and even
returning characters i was like i'm so
happy to see boomerang back here weirdly
i love rick flag this time around
weasel was cool weasel was something
else and even harley like harley is an
experience
where you were coming out of a few other
performances probably the most
performances of anybody in the dc eu
right now
and even she took on a different layer
for me in this movie so
yeah i loved the new characters that
they brought in as well as the way they
enriched the characters from before
i feel like we could just name every
character by the end of this
in terms of like who made an impression
and who was cool i had to choose who
would be your standout
characters for me it's probably polka
dot man because
he's such a ridiculous character james
gunn's writing
and the actor's performance really
brought a lot of layers to
what could have been a really silly
character a lot of layers a lot of
nuance and made him surprisingly really
cool and a serious threat ratcatcher was
absolutely beautiful she was the heart
of this movie in
many many ways she had a beautiful
backstory
had a lot of surprises i really
especially love sebastian which when you
see the movie you'll know what i'm
talking about
sebastian hands down number one
character
mvp i'm not being paid to say that she
really felt like a real grounded
character
she pulled everyone together it was
great oh and i mean i we haven't name
checked them yet so i feel
almost requisite but i mean bloodsport
idris elba
even though he's not maybe necessarily
the most flashy and wacky character i
thought he
really anchored the movie with a certain
level of the appropriate gravitas to
bring to something like this but also
purely badass and i don't want to spend
too much time comparing the two but he
did give
me the kind of oomph that i was hoping
havoc will smith in the first suicide
squad could have
even though he is one of the better
parts of that movie i really thought
that yeah bloodsport really brought
everything together especially kind of
being the eventual glue of the team and
of course i mean john cena's peacemaker
is a treat just because i mean you've
seen his wackiness in the trailer but
there is more that comes out of the
story and more i think that comes out of
that character
sort of in particular that's surprising
and and kind of juicy
also just shouts out to kingship that's
the problem is you start naming your
favorite characters
there's a lot of characters there are so
many if i can create a segue i guess
yeah you can thanks greg you can't josh
checking with you that was my subtle way
of checking with you
certain moments featuring king shark but
other characters as well in other
aspects of the movie they will go into
these sort of visual sequences that are
more tonal and that are
outside like the main plot that i can
imagine certain people being like
where were we focusing on this but to me
they really brought this sort of
perspective like i thought the movie did
a nice job jumping between the
perspectives of the different characters
who are along for this doomed mission
getting to have even just a few moments
of sentimentality and visual
storytelling with them brought a lot to
this movie and again coming out of the
previous which was like so heavily
edited and apt to tell you
everything this movie did a nice job of
pulling back when it needed to and doing
something more interesting when it
needed to
yeah it had plenty of grounding but it
also took you off to little dream states
at moments and it's it's what a film
should be as an art piece
yeah it felt like a bunch of issues
amounting to one big graphic novel to me
in a way especially with some of the
subplots some of the side stories and
and the way that
ultimately things kind of all come back
together and culminate what really makes
this movie special is the fact that
james gunn does a beautiful
job humanizing these villains these
antagonists traditionally in other
superhero stories
providing these characters little things
like either phobias or traumas with
their parents or whatever makes them
more accessible
to us as an audience while also playing
on those characters fears that make them
human
in a humorous way it's also very
shocking a lot of the violence is
incredibly showing and
super jarring but it is so strangely
deranged and that's what makes it
humorous and
it's it's right up my alley personally
the movie was very
non-linear in terms of storytelling it
was thematically
intricate yet it was very easy to follow
having a suicide squad
moving prior to this really establishes
what
can go wrong with the suicide squad
movie and this one does establish what
goes right james gunn does a fantastic
job
at really taking these like oodles of
characters and making you care about all
of them yeah absolutely and i mean i
think you know there are a lot of movies
that try to
tell things non-linearly or show you a
little piece of context and then come
back later and give you another side of
the story that you didn't know at the
time
i thought this movie did that with poise
and didn't do it just because it thought
it was cool but it did for me enhance
the tension and it did give me certain
of those little magic moments of like
okay while this was happening that was
happening and these two moments are
about to converge
and so it made the action of the story
feel quite alive and
well thought out shouts out to amanda
waller because the other thing
this movie did was it really grounded
her position
and the team's position and where
everybody stands in terms of what they
know and why
and what she is doing while she's
pulling the strings and so having a
little bit of foothold
in her world was a nice thing too
because the first suicide squad tells
you that amanda waller
is you know nobody you want to mess with
and this movie shows you that and it
proves
that and it also shows her exercising
some of the consequences she often holds
over the team's head
it really does feel real the stakes of
we have to go through with this you know
i gotta ask what do you think about
harley quinn
even though this is sort of a standalone
movie she does definitely show growth
so in some ways it's like i wanna i
wanna acknowledge some of the stuff from
even suicide squad but especially the
birds of prey movie leading into this
you can really see how much she has just
really grown
the sensibilities in writing that james
gunn brought to the character
changed her and involved her and
presented her wackiness her looniness in
a different kind of way in this movie
she's
been through stuff we've seen her love
the joker we've seen her break up and go
through the heartbreak of that and now
we're seeing her on the other side of
that while still keeping that sort of uh
would you say innocence i said nuttiness
innocent not
innocent nuttiness not she's very much a
killing machine but is also
a source of humor within the film and
she's learning as she goes last thing
i'll ask is
what if anything did you not like about
it
it's a spoiler now i don't know if
there's anything i truly honestly right
now
would have a big gripe with i guess i
wish i hadn't seen so many moments in
the trailer
certain character moments especially
humorous beats that just would have
played fresh had i not seen a lot
of them across the scope of the movie in
the trailer
funny wise i would agree with you yeah i
loved how this film
diverts your expectations tenfold what
you think you're getting is not quite
the movie you get that was a good thing
but it there were moments where it
didn't always cater to
what i would prefer i think the only
issue i had is this movie being called
the suicide squad there are certain
moments in the movie
where you see things happen whether it
be an explosion or somebody
falling through a building you're like
they definitely should have died from
that but you know it's a superhero movie
so like
it's kind of part of the genre you kind
of play cartoonish all right ratings and
wrap it up
you [ __ ] i give this movie
it's the best time it's a good time and
it's you should pay money to see it in a
theater and you should buy it on blu-ray
no alcohol required
if i had to put it somewhere within his
other filmography
within the superhero genre i would say
better than guardians 2
for me didn't quite hit as hard as
guardians 1. yes there was music in this
movie but i don't think it played
as integrally as it did within the other
movies that he's done but it was a lot
of fun like i'll give it like a 7.5 out
of 10.
yeah i would say i could watch more of
it i would put it at a solid
a plus but not quite an a plus plus
man if only you could get that extra
plus that it would be worth your time
and money
guys thank you for joining us today if
you've been one of the lucky people up
until the the release of this video
who's seen the movie leave your thoughts
down below try and keep them spoiler
free until the movie's out then it's a
free-for-all remember
to like comment subscribe all that good
stuff click the notification bell and
thank you again to cinemark for having
us
you can get your own private watch party
for 149 bucks whole theater to yourself
they'll even turn the volume up slightly
louder if that's your jam
be well and we'll catch you next time
i thought it was even better the second
time around